je m'excuse mais je vous prie d'excuser
j'apprécie je dis pas ce que je vais
encore être pas sympa et c'est vraiment
pas envie non excusées propos après vous
pourrez vous pourrez créer la parler je
vais simplement dire reichmann je trouve
que c'est un animateur extraordinaire
s'il a galéré pendant des années fait
des études et pas trouvé d'emploi dans
l'acting peut-être qu'il ya aussi une
raison
et franchement je suis limite gêné quand
je regarde les homes a t il pourtant
tout devrait bien ils écrivent ça encore
tu sais tu vois là il ya des influences
tout devrait plaire pandémie s'il est
nul il est pas bon alors juger sur pièce
devons isoler des moments de d'acting de
monsieur reichmann on regarde et on en
reparle après regardez
et je vois aucune trace de drogue rien
non plus du côté des profs y en a aucun
qui a été levée près - une affaire de
stups donc à dire que victoire d'étape
sur lui certaines ton show de la drogue
au cp c'est n'importe quoi c'est notre
boulot commandes ont été envoyés
d'urgence une ambiance au lycée
baudelaire
l'audience est reportée à demain
du cpar
tu vas pouvoir réfléchir un bon moment à
ta recette
parce que tu vas rester un paquet
d'années en taule à cause d'elle met toi
bien ça dans la tête mais c'est pas vrai
j'y vois pas que c'est pas postuler
muscat c'est vraiment la snob et gris
qui a échoué dans tout ce qu'elle attend
respectueux à francesca c'est avec
beaucoup ne voient pas mais dire ça ce
sont le cauchemar et demi c'est long
c'est une honte
c'est un acteur merveilleux je n'en rate
pas un épisode les scénarios sont
fabuleux son histoire avec sa fille
c'est ça marche parce que les gens
adhèrent et adore de rome jusqu'à taisez
vous oui pardon juste dire attends
francesca tu pourrais quand même être un
petit peu plus mais en six jours dans la
mesure où vous voulez ouais tu en sois
même s'il est chanteuse
je dire aujourd'hui douteuses sur vélo
soit la télévision mais non c'est pas
vrai mais c'est quoi ce pays où il faut
catalans n'ont pas dit je dire merde si
les animateurs demain il va être qu'un
cahier petit soin qu'actuellement
jeunesse qui excuse moi que l'état
venait suis vraiment mal fait comprendre
dans mon corps maintenant excellent il
faut pouvoir faire tout ce qu'on peut
faire avec ce que j'aime ou j'adore mais
ça me bouffe de chanter j'accepte vos
excuses
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'au niveau
j'en ai très mal aussi
non mais c'est l'acteur support parce
que finalement la commune i l'animation
c'est très proche compteur il ya de
grandes différences avaient compté en
est l'animateur est un peu d'actifs a
demandé à bernard montiel qui était très
bon procureur dans section de recherches
seraient a été procureur très bon euro
[Musique]
on a testé il était très bon je vais pas
signer n'importe quoi c'est sûr que pour
eux c'est une magnifique expérience est
très valorisant de pouvoir passer un peu
sur les téléfilms mais je trouve que
quand je regarde moi à léo mattei je
vois jean luc reichmann et j'aimais ce
matin j'étais comme ça la télé viva oui
bonsoir je vois je vois l'animateur en
revanche j'aime bien les animateurs en
tant que guest mais pas en tant que vrai
personnage récurrent caire pour rebondir
sur vos propos c'est vrai que comédien a
besoin que l'on parle souvent des stars
mais et comédien c'est un métier
compliqué d'y visiter des comédiens ont
beaucoup de mal à avoir du goût et c'est
vrai que je comprends que du côté des
comédiens parfois ça grince des dents
quand on voit arriver en haut de
l'affiché à l'animateur qui vous prend
le premier rôle qui généralement grâce
mon pays on parle de 150 180 euros par
épisode donc c'est quand même beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup d'argent c'est quand
même pas mal c'est vrai que je peux
comprendre en même temps racheté il ya
bien les acteurs qu'il est demandé sur
le pain les animateurs attendues et
testées de lui coller du fort boyard le
bol quelqu'un tous les animateurs sont
des chanteurs ou des actes aura t on
rêve tous radio
il ya une différence entre ce qu'on a
envie de faire et ce qu'on est capable
de faire et pour s'annoncer pas vraiment
qui ont par exemple c'est par exemple
moi je suis très mauvaise at heart walla
walla
[Applaudissements]